sportif de haut niveau et première femme
à boxer à la réunion il ya une dizaine
d'années dolores plusieurs fois
championne de la réunion et
vice-championne de france est devenu un
véritable leader dans son quartier de la
grande fontaine à saint paul
l'enseignement de la boxe française aux
enfants le rôle social qu'elle attribue
à ses actions son engagement politique
aujourd'hui et son incontestable sens de
l'effort de la persévérance sa
philosophie de la vie autant d'atouts
que se sont développées au fil de toutes
ces années qu'elle a passées dans son
quartier dans son club
l'un des plus dynamiques de lille
aujourd'hui au début la boxe française
seront de fontaine était pas très bien
connu cette année c'était un groupe de
jeunes qui est venu et qu'il voulait
faire la bourse française seront de
fontaine et monsieur marc roumain dans
son light est déjà dans un autre faisait
de la boxe française n'est pas sur le
quartier donc c'est lui qui avec ses dix
personnes ont essayé de créer un club
seront de fontaine et après bomba
ça c'est en 90 sont 91 quand je suis
arrivé bon à ce moment là c'était
restructuration on était en sélection
donc on a voulu créer notre propre club
avoir une identité au niveau de la
grande fontaine des gens de bonne
fontaine et puis bon bah c'est parti
tout seul
et puis comme vous pouvez le voir notre
association c'était en fait un groupe de
jeunes de camarades qui voulaient faire
des choses et quand on regarde bien en
90 on était à 5 6
et aujourd'hui ces cinq six si on a qui
travaillent avec nous on à monsieur
béatrice gibier qui était à l'origine du
club qui travaillent avec nous on à
monsieur berfeuil stefanki également
travaillé avec nous et il ya monsieur
marouvin il ya moi il y a
edmond david il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui en fait étaient là au départ et on a
fait en sorte que pendant ces années on
construit on se structure
on est un milieu associatif assez
conséquent pour pouvoir après travailler
tous ensemble
et parmi ces jeunes actuellement à ce
qu'il ya des champions en herbe et à
s'insérer elle il ya un à six bouts
cindy j'ai mis la tricasse y en a
beaucoup beaucoup et puis on a les plus
petites qui sont championnes de la
réunion tel que ce piranha y cynthia
elle est plus petite que vous avez vus à
la salle ce sont elles qui en ce moment
est en train de faire développer
beaucoup la boxe française quoi vous
avez le sentiment
c'était un domaine réservé aux hommes au
départ oui parce qu'en fait à la boxe
française déjà au niveau de la ligue
réunionnaise boxe française on n'avait
pas beaucoup de femmes souvent je me
trouvais tout seul ou à deux en tant que
femme pour
les conseils
les assemblées générales est bon
maintenant ça commence à évoluer un peu
mais c'est vrai qu'au début on a on a eu
un peu de mal à faire connaître la boxe
féminine à la réunion mais il ya des
personnes telles que dreinaza qui a fait
en sorte qu'on trouve sa place et
notamment l'ac thann et on a eu ce désir
et cascades qui est le président de la
ligue
de boxe française qui a voulu mettre
l'accent sur les féminines et également
sur les jeunes qu'est ce qui vous a
incité à pratiquer ce sport
à chaque fois je vis est en fait mon
frère qu à dominique était qu'ils
pratiquaient déjà la boxe on s'aide et
puis un jour il nous a dit moi et ma
cousine de venir faire de la boxe
française
on est allé on a rencontré monsieur axel
marouvin qui aujourd'hui est le papa de
ma petite fille on a sympathisé en fait
c'est lui qui m'a fait apprécier la boxe
française est d'autant plus qu'il avait
pas beaucoup de femmes à ce moment là
qui pratiquait la boxe française et
comme souvent il ya ma maman qui dit je
suis un garçon manqué donc c'est un
sport qui m'a tout de suite touché parce
qu'il faut un tempérament spéciale pour
pratiquer la boxe française
oui il faut peut-être pas spécial mais
il ya quelque chose qui se passe au
premier contact c'est-à-dire que étant
donné qu'à boxe française c'est un sport
complet où on apprend l'endurance la
vitesse et cetera
c'est parce qu'avant de faire à bord
sont sages et fait beaucoup d'autres
sports le tennis le volley etc
et quand la première fois j'ai pratiqué
la bourse conseille je suis tout de
suite que j'allais aimer ce à quoi donc
tout de suite j'ai commencé à faire des
assauts ensuite des combats avec mon
entraîneur on a travaillé très très dur
même le dimanche pour que j'arrive à un
certain niveau
et puis au fil du temps et à des
personnes qui ont vu que j'avais des
qualités et bon ben là on a commencé à
faire les championnats de france a
représenté la réunion lors des grands
galas internationaux et même du monde
ici est bon ben ça s'est passé comme ça
quoi vous parlez de qualité justement
que vous avez développé chez vous voilà
qui était déjà en boucle sur nos
qualités
en fait lorsque je pratique et je
pratique toujours mais j'encaisse
beaucoup au niveau des coûts c'est à
dire que je sais que je sais en donner
je sais
encaisser et puis à le côté ou
le fait d'être quelqu'un qui aime bien
les secours les sports de combat donc
j'apprends assez rapidement je m'adapte
et comme le dit mon entraîneur bon bah
je suis quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
potentiel mais qu'il faut faire
développer évolué au fil du temps nous
apporte la boxe française on aime
et bien ça c'est pour importer beaucoup
parce que j'ai appris au niveau
individus c'est à dire niveau de moi
même j'ai pu voir un peu quelles étaient
mes qualités
quelles étaient mes limites également
mais j'ai encore beaucoup à apprendre et
cela m'a permis dans le milieu
professionnel de m'affirmer de devenir
quelqu'un à part entière et bomba
actuellement
on est en train de voir un petit peu le
résultat quoi parce qu'en fait
moi ce que je voulais faire le plus
c'était d'essayer de montrer aux jeunes
filles que actuellement bon ben on a
aussi on veut on peut on a les moyens il
suffit d'avoir un peu de courage et
d'essayer d'aller de l'avant pour avoir
un avenir parce que c'est vrai qu'on dit
que c'est le destin c'est notre destin
et cetera mais c'est pas vrai il faut
quand même forcé son destin et faire en
sorte que bon d'ici dix ou quinze ans
elle aussi assez de place et qu'elle
évolue bien quoi elle devienne quelqu'un
qu'est ce que vous croyez inculquer aux
enfants en leur donnant goût à la boxe
française
en fait si on regardait autour de nous
on voit que la famille a tendance à se
diviser à les enfants avec
l'environnement qui est autour d'eux ont
tendance à oublier les règles
fondamentaux de la vie donc avec la boxe
française nous on essaie de leur
inculquer des règles qu'il faut
respecter
une manière de pas de penser parce que
la personne elle même à ses convictions
et ses années en tant que petit il ya
des règles à respecter il ya des choses
qu'il faut faire dire qu'il faut pas
faire et que bon en pratiquant un sport
telles que la boxe française et ben
c'est pas la peine de se bagarrer dans
la cour d'école ou quelque chose comme
ça parce qu'ils savent vraiment et ça
déjà leur valeur donc c'est un peu ça
que je vais la montrer
et puis à tout le côté d'insertion
professionnelle pour leur montrer que
bon même si on réussit pas trop à
l'école et à le côté sportif qui peut
aussi jouer un rôle au niveau de
l'insertion professionnelle et à toutes
ces choses qu'on essaie l'expérience que
j'ai eue que j'essaie de leur faire
passer
et puis le petit côté aussi affectif ou
on aime bien chaque petit parce qu'ils
ont des des mimiques ou des choses qu'on
apprécie et bon ben c'est un tout qui
fait que bon bah je les aime beaucoup et
je pense qu'eux aussi ils ont un petit
quelque chose pour manquons
ils seront deux fontaines on est en
train de faire en sorte que tout le
monde vide et au moins un petit contact
avec le milieu associatif pour que par
la suite on leur explique que dans le
milieu où on est en train de vivre si
l'enfant n'est pas équilibré dans sa
tête et dans sa vie de tous les jours ça
va dégénérer parce qu'il ya des
influences extérieures qui va faire en
sorte que à un moment donné ils font
succomber aux tentations et que bombay
pourront plus reprendre par la suite
leur éducation
c'est tout ça qu'il faut faire attention
et comment vous arrivez à les
ajustements parce que tout ce qu'on fait
on associe les parts ont tous les
projets qu'on monte on essaie de voir
avec des parents quelle serait la
meilleure façon de faire pour que eux et
leurs enfants soient associés pas ce
qu'il se passe c'est que les enfants
mettent une barrière entre parents et
enfants dont on essaie de réconcilier
les deux autour d'un thème surtout dans
le monde associatif pour qu'il se
retrouve un peu chaque jour avec on
semble qu'ils aient une haute vision de
la maman et de l'enfant qu'ils
apprécient ce certaines choses qu'ils ne
peuvent pas apprécié chez eux chez la
maman et l'enfant et c'est tout ça quoi
et c'est tout ça qu'on a envie de re
montrer aux parents mais sous une autre
forme pour qu'ils apprécient les
qualités de leurs enfants et que les
enfants de la côte est il apprécie les
qualités des parents parce que souvent
on n'arrive pas à bien s'exprimer entre
parents et enfants
et ça veut pas dire qu'on s'aime pas
conseiller municipal à saint paul depuis
les dernières élections
c'est un nouveau combat qui s'annonce un
défi que l'habitué des rings a accepté
de relever
je pense que la politique en elle même
on fait ça tout le long de l'année quoi
depuis 91
on fait de la politique sportive sociale
ont fait de l'insertion c'est quand même
sous forme de politique et cette année
bon ben si j'ai décidé de faire de la
politique politicienne comme on dit
c'est parce que j'estime que arrivé à un
stade il faut composer avec les hommes
politiques et que moi le si j'ai décidé
de m'investir c'est plus pour la
population de rançon ten pour tous les
saint-paulois en fait parce que je
trouve qu'il ya une partie de la
population qui souvent n'est pas
entendue qui n'est pas écoutés et que
ces personnes-là souvent lance un cri de
peut-être pas de désespoir mais ont
envie pour les écoutes
et lorsque pendant ces deux mois j'ai
travaillé en tant que politicienne eh
bien j'ai constaté qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de misère quelquefois morale
quelquefois physique mais que bon bain
auparavant on faisait pas attention et
que j'estime qu'en tant que conseiller à
je vais essayer de faire en sorte
d'améliorer les choses peut-être on n'y
arrivera pas tout à faire tout ça d'un
coup mais je vais essayer au moins
d'écouté d'essayer d'accompagner
que vous avez des congrès oui un rhdp en
particulier parce que j'estime que la
personne qui a été à l'origine de ce que
je suis aujourd'hui c'est mon père et
que bon bah actuellement il n'est plus
là et il n'a pas pu voir tout ce que
j'ai pu faire pendant ces dix ans c'est
à dire devenir la femme que je suis voir
son petit sa petite fille il y
maintenant à deux ans et demi et bon ben
en fait je voulais qu'il soit là mais il
n'est pas à quoi c'est pour ça que j'ai
tenu à faire cette interview chez chez
ma maman parce que elle compte beaucoup
pour moi et que j'ai envie que vu que lé
laquelle participe à tout ce que je fais
en fait quand on arrive sur arrive on se
rend compte qu'on est tout seul et c'est
un combat et dans la vie c'est pareil
c'est à dire que à chaque fois qu'on en
compte ce que soient pas à la recherche
d'un emploi d'un logement de n'importe
quoi on se retrouve tout seul il ya des
personnes qui vont nous aider au tour
mais à la longue on s'aperçoit qu'on est
tout seul et qu'il faut se battre tout
seul se battre et c'est pareil que ce
rallye je pense qu'il faut que tout le
monde garde espoir parce que quand
lorsqu'on perd espoir c'est à dire qu'on
a arrêté de vivre qu'on ne croit plus en
rien et moi je lance un message à tous
ceux qui qui arrive quoi les jeunes des
adolescentes et soto et toutes les
personnes qui croient en quelque chose
de continuer à croire de continuer à
vivre parce que de toute façon il rate
on peut crier une fois deux fois mais à
troisième fois je pense que ras
quelqu'un cliquait entendra et qui
tendra la main